do you remember this story from
Christmas morning when an armed teen in
Queens stole a French Bulldog from a dog
walker well now the trend continues out
west where shocking video shows a woman
in La clinging to the hood of a car that
thieve used thieves used as a getaway
vehicle you see the crooks stole her
French bulldog in broad daylight as she
was eating lunch in downtown my last
resort was to stand in front of the car
and tell them not to go and they drove
right into me and it pushed me onto the
hood and I just wasn't going to leave
the car at that point and I held on and
they took off now despite all her
efforts she has not had any luck getting
her sweet dog back and the thieves even
blurred out their license plate the
three women and man inside the kiaforte
went down Grand Avenue and eventually
swerved and she rolled off she tells us
this photo shows the car had Whited out
license plate just the last number is
visible
and who better to defend Joe Biden's
abysmal record than the guy who can't
defend his own abysmal record in
California who in their mind would want
to run uh when you have someone of such
esteem as our incumbent president of the
United States with a record of
accomplishments and a man of character a
man of decency I'm old school talk about
loyalty I'll I'll go to ends of the
Earth for this
guy oh my God if he is the answer to Joe
Biden well Donald Trump should feel very
good tonight it's not even a complicated
campaign we have the receipts we have
the best threeyear record of any modern
American presidency period full stop
except for the big thing approval yeah
Biden's approval is historically low why
everybody everybody we're
all former Speaker of the House new
gingr joins me now new I think of
California you know
people losing their even pets aren't
safe in California uh obviously a lot of
wealthy people moving out a lot of
people period moving out not because
they don't love the state because they
don't like the crime and the taxes so
who do you send out to make the case for
Biden the guy who help tank California
how does that work
out well look the Democrats have a huge
problem um rasmason for example today
said that 69% of the American people
side with Texas and only 27% are siding
with the federal government these these
are real uh this isn't Nome having a
fantasy as the former mayor of San
Francisco this is the American people
saying that this Administration is a
failure it is failing in the most basic
job of Defending America and as you
brilliantly pointed out earlier it's
failing to defend our troops overseas
and Nome who who again he's a little bit
of a flake he was the mayor of San
Francisco he lives in a fantasy land uh
so he can go around and say anything he
wants to but the truth is there is
nobody who is going to be able to defend
Joe Biden because the Biden record on so
many different fronts is going to be
somewhere between an embarrassment and a
disaster well he obviously can't really
do traditional campaigning and Americans
are just n sick of him uh look at this
poll
70% agree that Joe Biden should not run
for
reelection and his age is a main factor
obviously 74% saying he's too old to
work in government um new they're in a
pickle here they can't really get rid of
Biden but they don't really have anyone
else at this late
hour well and frankly Camala Harris
makes it harder because given the
demographics of the democratic party you
you can't just walk in and casually get
rid of an African-American woman uh no
matter how incompetent she is uh and so
this is where the tribalism effect of
the left traps them and so I mean my
personal guess and and here I'm a big
fan of Mark halin and he and I are in
total agreement I think Biden is going
to be the nominee I mean under what
circumstance I mean laa think about it
you have the White House you have Camp
David you have the Air Force One you got
Marine One or you can spend the rest of
your life bicycling in Delaware what
what's the upside for Joe Biden leaving
the White House voluntarily
now he's going to leave the White House
cuz the American people are going to
repudiate him and by the way there's a
London Telegraph poll this morning
that's amazing Trump's now carrying
people under 30 which is an area where
Biden had a 26o lead wow but they're
looking past ideology and they're saying
I can't get a job I can't buy a house I
can't pay off my student loans I'd like
to go back to that guy that got things
to work huge underlying shifts going on
in this country and N very quickly the
speaker of the house Mike Johnson has
said this Senate deal the outlines of it
have leaked out is Dead on Arrival uh do
you agree with what he's saying given
the fact that it does not limit Biden's
ability to parole people into the
country which could be obviously still
in the millions
look I've been an active Republican my
whole life every once in a while part of
the party becomes suicidally stupid that
bill is suicidally stupid it makes no
sense I I will oppose it every way I can
and I hope that every Republican
activist in the country will oppose it
it is a total sellout and it's just dumb
I mean it's like having a you know an
absolute winning hand and saying please
can I just lay these down and lose the
game anyway I mean all they got to do is
say we want to stop everything now not I
mean when I first heard that has it has
5,000 people a day gets to come in and
that doesn't count as illegal
immigration I thought these guys have
got I don't know what they're drinking
but it's not good n it's always good to
see you thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else